the talented man lost his life today
it's just a little pin Jim Cummings I
hear you feeling this has been me all
day Dan you should visit him you should
visit in prison and do voices move
through the funny so funny old
guess who's got your gig now this is
dangerous
now you go Jim Jim lonely in here man
I'm really serious they found out I'm a
rapist so they're just me man
do it as a darkwing duck oh I
know I guess who got you Winnie the Pooh
get oh if you think you got raped in
there talk to your man enjoy solitary
and they bumped my pay by the way my
cousin's a CEO and I think you're a
monster
have fun I'm just gonna put you in Gen
pop Oh George bought cellblock C and to
quote the great Jim Cummings let's get
dangerous
this is the story that I've had tweeted
at me I went on Twitter a couple days
ago
that's last time I was on I'm doing
pretty good I'd only go on Twitter about
twice a week now but I went on Twitter
but every time you this is the phone
melt fold down melt down folding the
crying punching someone DME this is the
story I've been deemed the most on
Instagram
ya ever have any stories every which is
everybody wants you to come yeah it's
like yeah but the voice actor the voice
of Winnie the Pooh was accused of rape
in animal abuse the same time same not
same thing different different rape on
raping women beaten dongs beaten dogs
what is it Christine its spousal rape
it's is accusing him of rape and then
sometimes your wife love with you she
don't wanna make love the father's gone
I'm gonna go back no word on and you too
don't love each other sometimes you're
alone with her and she doesn't give you
what you want so you have to take it
crystal that's like that Chappell joke
when he does you know he does his nephew
watching Pepe LePew yeah he's gotta take
the all day no yeah this is crazy
Stephanie Cummings alleges Stephanie
Cummings was a married to the day actors
Jim Cummings his ex wife has accused him
of engaging in physical sexual and
emotional abuse including but not
limited to death threats rape and
various sexual deviant behavior forced
upon me without my consent
yeah I'm gonna pin the tail do you keep
losing your damn tail I'm gonna call you
a piglet I don't like you make sure
we're a butt plug it has a little pig -
yeah yeah he's good she's gotta wear a
honey pot oh please please take off the
shirt I want to have sex
with you Jim without your shirt on
honey's not a good Lube it's really
grabbing on another occasion oh this is
great stephanie alleges jim rohn that's
not great i was really i wrote the
bottom of this is on another occasion
she claims he said he was allowed to
touch mommy's breasts since he paid for
them dude that's so great that he's like
surly drunk you know he's like cuz they
paid for but instead it's just Winnie
the Pooh and also in great amazing
awesome news he would slap his wife's
butt in front of their four-year-old
daughter and then forcefully put his
hand on back of her neck and kissed her
while holding her in place against the
wall that's all that false is here that
falls into your category of great lying
to the shitstorm don't do the voice
don't do the voice to make it easier on
the baby
Robin doesn't need me in all right
listen that kid is growing up and he's
getting his imagination interests it's
not it's not this voice actors mustache
to makes me think he's yeah back up to
the pictures - okay I just told her go
to read more okay it's not his mustache
yeah it's the problem for me it's the
soul patch underneath the little bear
it's a little bit of lower lip hair the
shine was doing it yeah yeah it's crazy
because he's just the voice of a sweet
bear where's the animal abuse I never
liked many of the pill what I was
promised and she also alleges that that
he abused their family puppy once
shattering its hip with a broom placing
placing it inside a metal bucket outside
of the house on a day which it was over
a hundred degrees and then left it there
for a long time well that's a dumb idea
for sitting in the pot also
lady hasn't heard of house training she
left it alone you put it in a metal
bucket at your puppy in a metal bucket
outside 403 well it's going to be
whether bonus he goes do you not bears
love more than honey he's crackpot puppy
I would need some cooked puppy right now
medium rare I just like I like you we're
doing Q do Winnie the Pooh actually
arguing for spousal rape as it's
happening is you Beach come on give me a
little yeah come on what you can take
care come on kiss me like you used to
why don't you want to I think I can take
all those kids David you're making him
so regal I wanna hear I'm just being
like a piece of
cook like you're fat you're nothing
more than a dumpster I take what's
mine cuz I keep the lights on look look
at me don't look at this you don't is
that pussies in my house it belongs to
me you know what this is this is where I
warm up slap yourself this is where I
warm up yourself tell the curtains
terrible tear them again call yourself a
donkey take off your underwear now stuff
them inside of you you're sad don't
stuff them what now I know stuff they're
up I want you to put your soiled
underwear in your mouth you slow
[Music]
yeah I should have never married a
Polack you're dumping people I can meet
your mom for five minutes and no this is
going nowhere mommy's just learning a
lesson
isn't that right here eight Spanish
piece of
yeah I know - you come to your
conferences that's what your
mother I'm sorry I guess your mother
she's walking around the neighborhood
with a big she's the one that's there
for me honey this will be hard for you
to understand but your should have left
that let's just say I should have kept
it an hourly rate with you yeah I did
it's up man it's up when
you find out if you tell her what you
saw Stephanie says they're gonna take
you away from us yeah how about you
who's abusing alcohol marijuana and
adderall dude sounds like Jim's a fun
Hank you would show up uninvited while
intoxicated on adderall kicking puppies
he was refolding towels all these people
Del's business ideas are flying what
about an uber when they pick me up in an
I Drive is ready for you senate ashton
kutcher because I think of Stephanie I
swear to god it's home ground level tell
me if I'm being weird I know I'm
hammered I know it's 3 a.m. I just had
this idea though we need to poo
restaurant yeah you're my ex-husband
this is inappropriate please you're
gonna wake Paul up and he's gonna be
pissed yeah
up on Stephanie a drink Sara
would win in the pool I mean yes she's
hot out Oh remember oh I'm out
of your league he is a human poo he
looks like he's my wife and I'll take
that whenever I damn well want it
there's his kids don't even want that
he's seen with them yeah are his kids
here for yeah she's well is she black
yes Mike and that guy come take her
touch my belly go on do it
did the wife of a the life of a front of
a cartoon voice person crazy tell you
this bet she can stomp on his
ego real quick goddamn cartoon bear Jim
give me more pants you you're a
bear act like you're an artist
because my dad's gonna take off and you
know sometimes sometimes they let me
actually do some small parts I do some
other stuff I do al can you find out
what other voices he did cause this
guy's super talented he's good
voice-over artist he do a lot of voices
oh he does a lot of voices there's like
a video of him doing a ton of he's
equally impressed with Cree summer
remember her from different world the
goose yeah she does that's her whole
living his voice over stuff Cree summer
I always see her name and Rugrats and
all that yeah I mean you know
there's people that what is this
a lot of money says IMDB who's Mickey
Mouse know Darkwing Duck dude he
couldn't have done it yeah he was he was
Arthur dark winter I don't believe this
now ya know Jim yeah it's jim Starlin
yeah jim Starlin no his name is Jim
Cummings
okay jim Starlin was another character a
boys look yay did dark moon ducky some
crazy ones go back go back go down to
the 90s work I saw
scooby-doo in there that's what I was on
below Clone Wars
that's the original Thundercats though
all right it was like there has tailspin
the karate you're moving around to the
point astronomers Garbage Pail Kids
movies he was nat nerd it was
afterburner on transformers this guy
couldn't know whose pound puppies peas
prince felt and news reporter he was
pound puppies keep going up so he's an
asshole Hollywood guy like got a wife he
would have gotten without success and
then forced her treated her like an
object and she got fed up and she loves
do the same it's hilarious that you
commit a rape in the same day that you
were like alright Jim that's good man we
got it you got it thanks guys
guys I'm horny I'm gonna go
my wife against her will he can totally
do poo with no pants on he's gonna get
into care you know this is how I get to
the voice he was in a bunch of stuff
using the little mermaid voice
uncredited a lot named scooby-doo
rest ship and Dale Rescue Rangers
Monterey Jack and Chippendales
that's pretty shut up it's fun who's
blue he was a huntsman as well and a
dwarf and Snow White
it's pretty big yeah he was rolling in
it just it's such it's such funny names
for a rapist yeah you're just saying
you're like oh he was huggable bear look
he was he was kissy tummy tummy gummy
gummy and then he's like he a bitch
this is my not testifying
his lawyer in court goes he goes you
don't know this brother the rape
character you can tell me gummy
something right here would take somebody
against there which I'm a jogger and
duck is a rape imagine if his characters
come back as character witnesses and
darkwing duck was a hero you're gonna
tell me Capitol critter raped this woman
it was raw zoo in Aladdin you may
remember him as bonkers from raw tuna
sheerluck bunk or what about Tiny Toon
Adventures he was Papa flea or net
de condor does nasty chondral here
rapist now is the rapist go up captain
clown bogus the plucky duck show he's on
a show called plucky duck and he's just
banging a door all lines at all showing
up God I just got done with the plucky
duck show goof troop yeah dude I
remember goof troop don't you write you
in a trailer sitting around all
day waiting for a people in the other
lines doing goof troop yeah I'm sorry I
want a warm meal and a wet mouth
I cannot believe he was darking duck
yeah Drake Mallard
herb muddle foot he was a rebuttal
yous doctor I've I want to do this off
your dude I wish they had a video
of him like that just being all like
super crusty he's like yeah oh yeah
y'all this blow right here
honestly go take it right in the butt
[Laughter]
cabin boy all right
he was cupcake Tiny Toon Spring Break
that was where I got a little racy
that's where he started getting into the
life he was he was Jack the donkey and
grumble the crow dude he didn't he did
work on Batman the Animated Series which
is the best version of Batman and Tiny
Toons after dark
that's so funny tired of her dark it was
a real mania devil does eatin
arguing yeah my orange juice Rhonda
Shear with little baby Tasmanian
Devil oh god I mean Lion King he was in
the Lion King
what the was ed come on dude was Ed
a cab driver the one guy he goes hey I'm
the only human
ed was driving a safari ed here Becky
Rodriguez is moving in I don't give a
rat's behind because I'm moving in
the heinous it is Becky or or EA's Peggy
or or EA's Becky I understand you're
taking picture for the bonfire and they
may be hasty oh wait ed is the name of
one of the hyenas can you bring up Jim
Cummings doing his voices because I
think there's like a mashup
mashup babies all I'm saying like give
me what's mine give me what's mine
sorry I have to rape in the voice first
in order to be the voice I had put your
aunt found a receipt Wow so make
it right now I'm gonna spit on it before
I take it you should do you should do a
word-for-word and mel gibson's rants
against this chick I told you to blow me
in the jacuzzi shut your mouth and blow
me here
I mean dude this guy's this is him Wow
well tweet it out at the bonfire sxm
this is Jim Cummings any ultimate Disney
voice off I don't know what that is but
you know order watch it so a minute 42
what do you guys got to do let us say
the danger yeah yeah you guys were right
you guys were a little too on
the nose there you know what is this guy
taking ass against weevils will you know
don't look at his wife actually don't
show the students boys if you could not
show this to mrs. coming Jim will see
you and wife on the red carpet I trust
she has
she if she's out of her purse bear her
punishment closet now she's just getting
sad
Disney expert I appreciate you higher
monsters practices straight up you built
a wall around Florida oh you became the
one thing that user terrified of mice
twelve tribes problems Walt Disney's
grandniece backs up Merrill streets
racism claims anti-semite check
misogynist of course let's go this video
Jim Cummings Wow
oh you know girl looky here get
dangerous yeah just just let's good
change a bit let's give I totally see
this to raping chicks
what is a dog don't ask me for car cuz
it's kinda like a poo let's let's guess
you start to roll the other in the
dangerous forces damn first off jump you
the cow Jake and I have a wall shaking
it can you give me my moment sure it's
not by myself it's not the meter I'm not
a psychopath
it's flashcards with vecchio hallway and
we do training tiger mom style yeah if I
do write frightened tourists like it I
get carbohydrates I nail you like you
have I have chorus some carbs bread
maybe some light noodles stove is on the
[Music]
by Jewish chip will slice a chaise on
the side
tell me again these really really
talented and I'm quitting the ship he's
not it's stupid
what are you doing is buffoonery it's
pretty cool
we could all do it it is cool just pay
for but every one of us can do this
yes I could do say let's get dangerous
in that cat's voice just discover here
that can let's get dangerous pretty good
why wouldn't it be good it's just not my
voice that's all he's doing
let's go to the tape let's get dangerous
yeah do that thing I mean it's basically
all the same voice it's mindless stupid
work if this guy had money for what he
was doing he wouldn't have that no skin
cancer whatever is happening up there he
wouldn't he wouldn't have to rape either
yeah he beat be rain and on him he
would have to his own dumb wife do
what if somehow he just hears this and
he just he's all bearded up and
crazy on that or all just outside top of
the Fox building what can only be
described as the first mass shooter with
[Laughter]
in-between clips he would talk in a
different silly cat voice getting lit up
by a rabbit the price
I've been radicalized playing oh oh the
caliphate will stab
I always say why not murder the
Westerners they seem so tedious
now I must produce I thrush I his
mother's danger all those ok I'm coming
for the students job Darkwing Duck we
all are - stop it we're all going for
this guy's - everyone did I want to be
the only one that applies ok Jake look
at that's my first time you smiled in
four weeks because he thinks he could do
this job please Christine don't hold me
back on this guy's wild town any longer
dark dark dude I don't know Darkwing
Duck voice you're saying voice just go
from your go from your soul then are you
him you're missing what I'm
saying
I do appreciate Mike you tell me to go
for my soul and I appreciate the crystal
you put my pocket before you said saying
it is I can just do like if you're like
pickle poisonous for this guy don't just
walk through it that was Italian
dark quick dollar wasn't good
dangerous get dangerous yeah do you want
to get dangerous you think I don't get
the injuries but play play a duck of
course my wings are dark Sebastian
Darkwing Duck the in red duck me it's
dark it's always guarded you're so wing
a particular why is it cold darkwing
duck shouldn't be cold dog of course
it's a dark wing it's a dog you're
feeding me the crust that the bow
emphasis maybe the senile Seinfeld I
forgot about seems nice
where's the Filipino nurses are stealing
all my stuff put on a Rutger
Hauer Lancers demo tape what I misspoke
it these things puzzle awful he's in the
blue man do you supported this rapist
for so long supporter rapist you said it
you said he was so talented he could
have done this you had his poster on
your wall I started freaking telling
calm guys I'm doing a benefit all the
proceeds are going to the legal fees
that lying bitch of an ex-wife he is
like oh look at that just lying go
Jesus Christ and she's a victim
look at that tall drink of lies
nah man that that look like that looks
like a guy that flies off the handle cuz
he knows she's out of his League
and when I'm here to victim-blaming sand
it was so much bigger I mean totally he
looks like he gets drunk and he's like
honey who's she what are you
texting your trainer again is that what
you doing oh she's like Jim please not
in the pool boys get dangerous just Jim
are you drunk yes
no dangerous I just say that 500
times today so you can keep this
you live your life where were you we're
soul cycle yeah let's go dangerous with
Derrick training you again and you love
Derrick se+ the jams
mmm it's contagious you say really knows
how to get you moving I know what the
let's get dangerous put the revolver
down I haven't put them but right here
guess what you're about to blow the head
off the receipts oh he's a piece of
yeah rot in hell right now weirdest
thing that I read so she left and took
the kids to Utah in 2017 to visit the
kids and he was standing she woke up to
him standing over her with an erection
well like her kid was in bed with her
right to get away from this guy and he
keeps doing creepy stuff to like keep
her under he slaps her she sits up
anyway you have 12 new messages message
one let's get dangerous I'm gonna kill
you when you sleep you stupid bitch I'm
on my way to your mom's house
this is the last time I'm gonna say this
and I mean it's so listen up you are
going to die I feel like I have the
right youth form of God fury I am the
sheep and the shepherd and the cop comes
over he goes hey ya again detective
esprito Santo at Bundy monocle
he's destroying around he's tinkering
with some Latin so I'm gonna have my
back to the camera but not to Jay I
would never turn my back on Jay for you
know for the right price maybe I I don't
know I wouldn't turn on you I mean I
might I don't know
see an angel we don't know we done we
without texting your other co-hosts yes
[Music]
and Christine's like really eating soup
like she's on production taking a break
wheeling and dealing Christine huh
Christine what kind of soup did you get
sweet corn chowder with bacon
it's basically sugar stew am i right
she don't give a she doesn't
observe the same rules
all right then that's for a cow Jay well
he's got me fighting your battles what'd
you say dad no matter how hard you don't
like you're eating chowder I hate it you
think it's making it look big I don't
agree with that looks fantastic you're
gonna eat it you're trash are you making
bread croutons
why are you pretty mad at her no not at
all
okay
it's definitely ruining it do you feel
betrayed
hello for bread in that thing that's the
other piece of bread
Christine also keep that thing down that
homeless guy might come back and
swipe there like a hawk oh that guy's
coming like a like a hungry
pigeon yeah like a Bronx pigeon who just
hit paydirt chuckwagon
Time Lord you got settler food yeah
that's the kind of bread they give you
at a shelter yeah
take this to fill your stomach's you're
not gonna eat for a couple you want us
to circle the wagons so no coyotes come
and take your stew you made it a
bread bowl why are you putting the bread
on the top Thanks decide to go back at
it
welcome to the bonfire ashamed I look at
loo look at how great black looks what
dr. Steen she just brings it right out
you know just parks herself like she's
an art installment he's bred
or depends how fat then they go I don't
give a anymore you're not gonna get
better breath before than when you're in
public to freeze your bag oh yeah oh
this my vegetable chips and tuna fish
didn't get enough bonfire
well like subscribe follow all that
stuff at the bonfire sxm on Twitter
Instagram snapchat or wherever you do
computer stuff you know all the computer
places